je voulais qu'on parle du flop des JO
quand même parce que patrick Montel doit
être avec nous et c'est vrai que la
billetterie alors j'ai découvert ça hier
c'est les gens sont pas contents il y a
3 millions de billets qui ont été vendus
il y en a un million simplement à 24
euros et c'est une blinde pour reprendre
de vos expressions tout à l'heure donc
c'est pas c'est pas sérieux franchement
de proposer des JO faut des JO en France
je suis non mais je suis d'accord vite
avec j.i.go joue au parcours du
combattant que représente l'achat de
tickets pour les JO comme pour de vrai
tu t'es préinscrit il y a 6 mois tu fais
partie du club Paris 2024 tu as enfin
compris que tu étais tiré au sort en
fouillant dans l'espace la chance alors
connecte ta figurine sur le site
officiel dans le créneau qui s'est
alloué big partout dans l'espoir de
choper un Pâques personne n'en voulait
dire
est-ce que mais en même temps bon on va
pas faire je peux faire mon vieux
grognon c'est formidable les gens vont
courir vite ils vont sauter haut ça va
être bien bon
alors bien fait de venir
où sont les places à 24 euros il y en a
plus heureusement j'ai pu acheter des
places pour le tir à l'arc à Châteauroux
et pour seulement 425 euros voici
une infirmière du Wisconsin a été démise
de ses fonctions en attente de son
jugement après avoir pratiqué un axe
médical savez-vous ce qu'elle a fait
l'euthanasi actif non non
j'ose pas
arrivé avec un problème d'engelure au
pied et lui a coupé le pied
[Musique]
elle affirme avoir voulu lui donner un
peu de dignité
sauf qu'en fait elle serait d'une
famille de taxidermiste et le projet
c'était aussi de
poser le pied dans l'entreprise
familiale avec un écriteau portez vos
bottes les enfants non c'est pas vrai
elle va prendre cher
[Musique]
c'est sûr
c'était sûr le problème pour les
indemnités le monsieur va peu en
profiter très peu étant donné qu'il est
décédé la semaine d'après après après
l'amputation et je pense que la famille
va bien se retourner
c'est pas le pied
[Musique]
c'est la mairie de Paris qui en a
éprouvé le besoin Charlie et la
chocolaterie le bon gros géant ou encore
Mathilda intemporel ces histoires de
Roald Dahl ont fait le tour du monde et
viennent d'être modifié avec l'accord de
ses ayants droits afin selon eux que les
enfants d'aujourd'hui continuent de les
apprécier illustration dans Charlie et
la chocolaterie il était grave avant il
est devenu maigre comme une allumette
dans la nouvelle version le mot gras il
se passa a été supprimé par exemple dans
Charlie et la chocolaterie ils ont fait
remplacer le terme gros par celui de
énorme ce qui fait réagir Tristan de
Nantes qui nous dit dans le cas présent
je vois pas bien l'intérêt parce que si
je dis à ma copine mais non tu as pas un
gros cul il est juste énorme elle le
prendra pas beaucoup mieux ça marche pas
mieux autre exemple avec cet extrait du
bon gros géant quelque chose de tout
noir de tout noir et de tout grand de
tout noir de tout grand et de tout Mince
ici le mot noir sera remplacé par sombre
si seulement ils avaient un peu
ludickens ou Kipling dans cette autre
passage l'écrivain regarde Kipling 7 sa
place à l'écrivaine Jane Austen qu'elle
soit caissière dans un supermarché même
chose avec le terme caissière remplacé
par scientifique de haut niveau je vous
emmène aux toilettes avec moi ce sont
des toilettes qui datent de 1905 à
l'origine vous voyez c'est c'est écrit
ici donc c'est un voyage dans le temps
que je vous propose allez on y va comme
si on était des clients alors ce sera
pas gratuit ce sera 2 euros l'entrée
mais alors regardez ce qui nous attend à
l'intérieur on a la dame pipi comme
avant alors non en fait si je dis dame
pipi vous faites les gros yeux pourquoi
vous voulez pas qu'on disedom pipi on
nous appelle plus des malins pipi on
nous appelle des hôtesses d'accueil et
d'entretien 61 entreprises britanniques
qui ont été suivies pendant quelques
mois par l'Université de Cambridge pour
évaluer si de travailler un petit peu
moins en termes de temps on passe de 5
jours par semaine à 4 jours dans la
semaine en réduisant le temps de travail
donc ça veut dire qu'on va pas condenser
avec de grosses semaines et bien est-ce
que ça avait un impact sur la qualité de
vie des salariés pourquoi vous faites
quoi de plus que dame pipi alors on
accompagne chaque client dans des
toilettes qui sont nettoyées après
chaque passe
c'est que vous les nettoyer à chaque
fois alors je vous emmène aux toilettes
bon alors c'est pas la révolution non
plus vous reconnaisserez les vous
reconnaîtrez les lieux il y a le petit
le petit lavabo le miroir et alors
150000 euros ont été dépensés pour
remettre en état ses toilettes et
effectivement lorsqu'on travaille moins
et bien on a des chiffres assez
incroyables puisque 71% des salariés
connaissent moins d'épuisement
professionnel 39% se disent moins
stressés par rapport au début de l'essai
et le nombre d'arrêts maladies a baissé
de
65%, alors regardez ça je trouve ça
vraiment très drôle ça c'est un compteur
qui était actionné par la petite barre
là et c'était pour éviter que la dame
pipi à l'époque ne tape dans la caisse
voilà on savait combien de clients
étaient venus et a priori de combien
était la recette c'est incroyable
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
sauver le micro
c'est la seule émission pour un mec se
jeter comme ça
ici ils savent qu'un micro ça nous fait
la marche de l'émission